you're watching
this go have your food if you haven't
had it watch
out let's
go you don't have it that should have
been
son
come
on trade out trade
out show up more and know the
techniques make it work make it
work grab it go traic go
[Music]
go control come on what do you want what
do you want what are you missing nothing
go
[Music]
yes
keep your
mind control maintenance
right come on come on come on come on
you're thinking too
much go to S for that it's either in the
fold of your arm or you're in
Sonic you your mind use your mind you
got to B you got to F so you get room to
fall
bre get out of the turning
wasting C your
hole you're not fading man you're not
fading it's not going to work on a
stronger
guy you have a slide t con at the end
you move up the circle with both
hips add the attempt me protect the
center
line come on man don't pull his shoulder
up get the Tami
R shove them down
Ray get that shoulder down to protect
yourself Tristan put the other hip
up
[Music]
get your tamy in
there
chers
you switch
sides someone
start you got to get the M you want to
emphasize weapon capacity not
pinny so fa
fa no room for a shoulder the way you're
doing it
yes same thing no room for the
shoulder F oh my gosh
d f there you
go the the should the head knee f
in a ton fashion so they fall into the
hole go go
go too
much what's your attempting where's your
stride he's going to grab your knee and
flip you over the last me we did I
should
say
stop
fighting holy
cow stop biting your lip get your atmi
in
there breath drop your shoulders drop
your shoulders do the technique right
fix your hands where's it go where's it
go flat on your chest you have no idea
you're going to run
again hurry
up
relax move your body there's no room for
him to fall
there had to
move
right then what what does your do they
scoot
out boom okay find the space where his
shoulder's going to hit and I'm going to
end up
in he's supposed to still fall see
not here it's not there you see my
body so Chris I I want to emphasize draw
my weapon so see I can draw my weapon
from here boom if I'm here like this and
he's on me I can't do
this so you exercise the m the
m James is relational so I don't go well
he said fade that's too far right
James boom up
again boom so where he just Falls right
into the lock okay
go make it
seamless
more
[Music]
space live
up fill the
gaps Bend his arm with the other arm
don't over his
hand fill the gaps you
[Music]
can push your Center forward don't
rotate your waist don't rotate your
waist push your Center forward push your
Center Drop
It
Go
so here's what I mean by
the so I am the live
who that's a hole right what are you
supposed to do
good what's
happening not far enough she she's too
close it's not I'm not fading you're
grounding
me
boom Oh you going to
pin are you are you is she no
no
is she going to
pin do you
see boom this are here around go stay
there grab resist resist resist don't
let me get you
over now there going to work if you have
a KN no okay so when I come around here
this arm goes there you see this arm
then you're going to fade then you're
going to end up in my
pin pop where's your
block so you're just resisting here
that's going to hurt
you there see how she just Falls so
right now now what are you doing
resisting okay so take your
stretch you're still you're still
freaking
out then you
tap
go that's it come
on so when they KN kneel up like that
knel on her back guess
second no you're doing the same thing
right use the second hand and now make
room for her to
[Music]
fall
pull don't lift the arm don't lift the
arm don't lift the arm not lift it sink
it down Okay hold it on your chest here
go push that elbow forward with your
Center
push the elbow forward with your Center
don't rotate your weight they're just
already be here pin
it it grab it grab it don't have okay
bend it and now push your Center
[Applause]
[Music]
forward
yeah
[Applause]
maintenance let's
go Jonathan go
with
dominate the center line right
[Applause]
away stop musing Fai
fa
right stop start over he's already there
get your get your hand right in his
face and boom then you
go push your
Center push your
Center don't Brun the hand do it's
back
push his elbow towards his head with
your
Center you're lowering the
[Music]
hand go to the other
one hey
he
hey there you go and it should go right
into it go right into it
right right into it right there you guys
understand that all all this is part of
your
timing it's not a setup
move right into it you see you guys are
all after the F because you're here
first of all then you shove them
down please will you okay no the whole
ending is part of the technique see I'm
already thinking where I'm going to be
boom okay let's
go no mental
phas
[Music]
nope
have to fade
away lock
it hands not
right where's
your
over start over
you want to see
a your hands up in his
face hey
he hand up
right
enough
make work good
Gooding okay partner where's your strike
how many times did you have to get
hit how many more do you want to get hit
okay then make it so all right cuz if
you have a special request we'll just
get all the strikes out of the way first
go you got to pay attention you
should
that
right fade
fade get it right get it right put it
right put it
right come on come on girl it on your
chest it then you go
good very nice
transition good get it
yes come on
f f he's too big
F
don't brace on the
[Music]
map sides hurry up take your to the
other side last one to start got 100
Push that's you will take them
out
Virginia very much keep
[Music]
training
good that
P
so you see your checking out get block
block then I'm going to use it
see I use
it don't just let it check you dead it's
a
contact
expect that and you use it not finding
my
[Applause]
Center
[Music]
sides
go come
[Music]
on come
on go
[Music]
[Applause]
M terrible that's not going to work so
you missed the
Mage go to
standing
right you have to
[Music]
play
make it
work up right watch the
M it
worked what I'm five bended it's going
to hurt so you let it
relax you're not letting it relax okay
[Music]
go no
excuses grab is growing holy
[Music]
cow you already have 20 minutes of
practice so let's
go don't lay his hand
down
don't bring his hand towards his
back fix the
hand heel down the head knee goes down
grab Josh let's go
grab keep
connection push your Center don't bend
over push your cental forward towards
his head so aim yourself towards his
head turn your stance towards his
head